almost five years ago at apple's 2016
october event
apple revealed their brand new
redesigned macbook pro
which had an incredibly good looking
design that was thinner and lighter than
the previous model
and to this day it still looks
incredible
even compared to some of the brand new
windows laptops out there the only
downside was that apple replaced the
large variety of ports that we used to
have
on the 2015 macbook pro with a very
simple
4 thunderbolt 3 ports which use the usb
type-c design
this basically caused an uproar from the
community
with people upset about having to buy
expensive dongles
that weren't widely available on the
market since many computers at the time
didn't even have a single usbc port on
top of that
apple's beloved maxsafe connector was
completely scrapped on the new macbook
pro
which also made a lot of people upset
and the sd card slot
also scrapped forcing people to buy
adapters
and on top of that they replaced the
magic keyboard keys
that everybody loved with the butterfly
keyboard
that everybody hated so what ended up
happening was that a lot of people
decided
not to upgrade to the new 2016 macbook
pro
and they were literally buying the old
2015 models instead
even a couple of years after the
redesign came but thankfully
apple has finally gotten rid of the
butterfly keyboard with the latest
macbook pros
showing that it was a huge mistake in
the first place
so if apple is capable of doing a full
u-turn
on mistakes like the butterfly keyboard
what if going with the full set of usb-c
ports was also a huge mistake and the
reason i'm bringing that question up is
because the latest leaks and rumors
are showing that apple is having a
massive change of heart
in terms of the ports with them
basically bringing back
all of those old ports according to
leaks and rumors from very reliable
sources
like bloomberg's mark german the m1x
macbook pro
is gonna be coming with a mag safe
charging connector
which is a huge surprise to a lot of
people on top of that
both the hdmi port and the sd card slot
are coming back as well with the sd card
slot now rumored to be featuring
much faster uh s2 speeds and these new
ports including the max safe connector
have basically already been confirmed by
leaked schematics
that were stolen from apple in a
ransomware attack
so what all of this shows is that apple
is for sure
reviving the ports and mac safe on the
new
m1x macbook pros that are going to be
coming this fall
and now that we know all of that the
important question we have to answer
is why and that's what i'm going to be
answering in this video
because i personally believe that apple
has had a master plan
in the works for many many years that
has finally been
accomplished so let's get into that now
it might seem like apple is finally
ready to admit
that switching to a full set of usb-c
ports was a huge mistake
but i don't think that's the case at all
i did a little digging and i found an
old article from 2015
that claims that apple actually invented
the usb
type-c port which sounds absolutely
insane
but check this out according to john
gruber the famous apple blogger who owns
the daring fireball
apple invented usbc and then gave it
away
to be an open source standard but apple
couldn't really say it was theirs
because they didn't want people to see
it as an apple port
but as a standard port for every product
out there
and if you want some proof to go along
with that idea apple was in fact
listed as a contributor for the new usb
type-c
specification but they didn't want to
take all of the credit for it and if
you're wondering why apple would do this
well if it was called the apple usb c
port
many of the stubborn companies out there
wouldn't want to adapt it because it
would make apple look good
and if apple made it an open and free
standard
people would point fingers at apple for
charging royalty fees
for their lightning port but not the
usbc port
which would cause a pr mess so they just
kept it a secret
so here's the next question that we have
to answer if apple did truly invent usbc
why in the world would they do this and
how would they ultimately gain anything
from it
well we already know that apple went all
out and replaced the previous ports that
everybody loved on the macbook pro
with just 4 usb-c ports causing a ton of
controversy
and many upset customers so why would
they go through
years of backlash just to bring those
ports back
on the m1x macbook pro well here is
where the master plan comes in
the truth is that if apple didn't make
the bold move of scrapping all the old
ports
and literally forcing people to use usbc
on the new redesigned macbook pro then
usbc
would not be where it is today with the
entire computer industry
basically embracing it less than five
years after
apple's bold move basically every single
computer on the market now comes with at
least
one usbc port and amazon is now flooded
with every type of usbc adapter cable
and hub that you can imagine and apple
was hands down the company that pushed
the entire industry forward and if you
really think about it
if none of this ever happened and usbc
was still a niche connector
then apple's brand new 24-inch imac
would not be
possible because as all of you guys know
it's so incredibly thin
that usb-a ports physically can't fit
into the chassis
they even had to design a special power
cable
with ethernet built into the power
supply because
even that can't fit into the 24 inch
imac
so apple literally had to make usbc
go mainstream to make the 24 inch imac
as
thin as they wanted it to be which is
something that sets apple products apart
from everybody else and that's why apple
is so obsessed with thinness
going even further the rumored m2
macbook air redesign
is going to be so thin that usbc is
quite literally
the only port that will fit on the side
basically hitting the limits of how thin
a laptop can get
so yeah it now makes total sense why
apple forced people to use
usbc way back in the day and now it's
finally time to answer
the main question why would they only
now
revive ports and mac safe on the m1x
macbook pros
well the first reason is that apple has
succeeded in their master plan
of making usbc go mainstream so they no
longer have to force users to use it
and today their super thin lower end max
are totally fine
with only usb-c ports and the second
main reason
is the big one apple wants the m1x
macbook pros
to be the ultimate laptop for everyone
and to do that apple's going to try to
make everybody happy
all at the same time to disrupt the
entire industry
and take over a huge portion of the
laptop market share
so what they're gonna do is bring back
all of the ports that everybody loved
like the sd card slot the hdmi port
and especially the mac save charging
connector
and then they're gonna pack in the apple
silicon m1x chip
that will outperform basically every
other laptop out there
in terms of real world cpu performance
they're also going to make a huge push
into the gaming market
by giving it a 32 core gpu option
that will rival some of the best gaming
laptops out there
while being much thinner and not
requiring it to be plugged in
to get all of that power and even with
all of that performance
the battery life is going to be much
better than any other laptop
out there they're also going to pack in
a brand new mini led display
and a 1080p webcam both of which people
have been complaining about for years
and on top of all of that it's gonna
have a great looking redesign with
premium build quality
it's gonna have the best speakers out
there it's gonna stay
cool it's gonna stay quiet and it's
gonna be
incredibly reliable as well so what i'm
trying to say is that if apple can fix
all of those issues that people
complained about to create
the ultimate laptop then they can do a
huge marketing push to grab
as much market share as possible which
will probably be enough
to make triple a game developers take
apple seriously
again which would in turn increase
apple's laptop market share
even more and that right there is why
apple is reviving the ports and mac safe
on the m1x macbook pros now if you
totally disagree with me
then comment your thoughts down below
but if you enjoyed this video tap
like and click the circle above to
subscribe for more videos like this one
and definitely check out one of those
two videos right over there
thanks for watching and we'll see you in
the next video